[Music]
you are a huge name probably the biggest
name in comedy right now and you could
have a private island to hang out on but
everybody has to start somewhere when
you started out it was it was rough yeah
it was tough going and if it may yet be
getting that kid was tough I mean you
know talking about a comedian man I used
to do uh spots for food
you know doing stand-up comedy uh so
when you go tough you're talking my the
guy who used to perform live shows in a
bowling alley I don't know one time I
was on the show right there's only 15
people there but every time I went to go
tell my punchline somebody threw a
strike then serious it's a blind bowling
alley a bowling bowling I'm in the
middle lane there's people bowling down
here people bowling out here and I'm
like man listen I don't know about y'all
bag man I just kept starting over and
over again now you had to live for a
while you could didn't even really have
a place to live do you no no no I I
don't like to say not a place to live
yeah you know you're right I didn't but
my mom my mom kind of my mom a lot
support system you know uh when I needed
an apartment and I went and got one on
my own I couldn't afford the rent
because I was trying to do comedy so my
mom she's very religious she said look
Kevin I'm gonna put you on my back I got
you for a year you can go out do what
you want to do I'm gonna support you
after that you don't find a way to feed
yourself then you got to go you got to
go back to school you got to do
something productive I said mom okay
give me a year during this comedy so my
mom was very overly just she was always
always telling me to pray read my Bible
I need rent money it's come time for
rent money I'm like mom you didn't even
rent this month she's like what did you
read your Bible
I'm like mom look I don't have time to
talk about the Bible stuff right now I
need the money like this thrill they're
gonna kick me out she's I read your
Bible and then talk to me Mom okay
goodbye hangover mom I don't go to this
another month go by I'm getting eviction
notices mom stop playing like if you
don't give me this money I'm gonna be
homeless
did you read your Bible I don't want to
read the Bible right now I'm not gonna
have a place to read it in a minute if
you don't give me the money
she's like look I'm not gonna do this
with you Kevin read your Bible talk to
me it gets close to the third month I'm
like oh my god like they're really
threatened and kicked me out I finally
opened up my Bible when I open it up my
mom put all of the checks
the rest of the air in the Bible so I
open it and all of my rent checks fall
out and I just sat there with the
dumbest look on my face
call my mom I said mom I see what you
did you put it in the Bible she said did
you read it no but I got the check
[Applause]
you